what's up guys so as you guys may know I
just finished my PC build series in
which I unboxed and reviewed every part
I use in it and made a time-lapse build
as well so if you guys are interested in
any of that then make sure to click the
link in the description below
for the playlist there are a lot of guys
out there who are a bit frightened to
build your own PC or are overwhelmed
with information and don't know if you
guys are up to task of building it by
yourself and may want to consider a
pre-built this PC was the first PC that
I've built in this video I wanted to go
over all the challenges and my overall
building screens so let's jump right in
first of all I had to choose the parts I
wanted for my PC this process was very
extraneous so I'll be making a dedicated
video on it so check that out if you
guys are interested once I chose my
parts and got them delivered I was ready
to build for the entire build I only
needed a small Phillips head screwdriver
and a larger one I didn't buy any other
building materials such as zip ties
magnetic screwdrivers and anti-static
wristband or any other extract building
accessories like that unless you guys
want a specific color of zip ties I
recommend you guys just to use the zip
ties that come with the motherboard
power supply in case together they give
you an abundant amount of zip ties and I
doubt you'll I will ever run out as for
the anti-static wristband well I did
some research and I couldn't really find
any cases that people actually short
they're shorting out their PC parts
because of the static so obviously that
was very rare so as long as you guys are
careful and touch the power supply once
in a while you guys will be fine no one
in my family has ever built a PC before
and everything I learned about building
pcs was from the internet there are
hundreds of guides on how to build a PC
and a solution to every niche problem so
it's very easy to learn as a result
don't avoid building a PC because you
guys are worried about not knowing what
to do it's very easy to learn and does
not take that much time so don't be
intimidated by that here are some things
that I found all been difficult when
building my PC first of all the
motherboard is so hard to put in right
with the i/o shield
I tried putting the i/os shield in first
and then the motherboard and then I try
to put into iOS shield onto the
motherboard first and putting all inside
at once but then I went back to
traditional method again and honestly it
was pretty difficult but as there were
some metal prongs on the i/o shield
they're supposed to bend in when you put
them on the board but the prongs are
super stiff on my motherboard and it was
really a pain and took about 15 minutes
for such a simple task next I don't know
if this is just my case but the
motherboard screws are kind of difficult
to screw in and the threads that the
screws aren't perfectly made so it
doesn't feel too sturdy but since you're
really not going to moving your piece he
around that much well the screws aren't
really gonna get loose or anything like
that next if you guys are getting an a
IO then you guys are gonna have a bit of
trouble installing it because the tubing
is just super stiff and very hard to
manipulate it's very annoying also on
the radiator make sure to tighten the
screws really well or else you will get
a very annoying rattling sound coming
out of your PC at all times
also I have found this same issue on the
fans as I did the motherboard screws the
screws on the fan are also very hard to
screw in the threads are very small this
next one isn't really an issue but it is
a bit concerning if you guys are buying
an Intel CPU it takes a lot of force
today what's locking the CPU into its
place you feel like you're about to like
break the motherboard so but nothing
actually happens so just keep that in
mind as a result definitely make sure to
install the CPU outside the case because
you don't want to crack your motherboard
same goes for installing your ramp make
sure to do that outside the case
unfortunately the 24 pin cable is
something you're going to have to
install inside the case but it also
takes a lot of force so just make sure
reinforce the motherboard by putting a
few fingers underneath it when plugging
in that cable if you guys are getting a
cased with tempered glass then make sure
to not remove the protective film on it
or else you guys will get your
fingerprints all over it and smudge it
and you'll have to clean it again
so wait till the end of end of your
build to remove that film cover finally
make sure that all your PC parts are
paddle when I say this I don't mean go
to PC part breaker and see if it says
compatible
I mean manually check if each parts
compatible with each other for example
many reviews of my case highlighted that
vengeance led Ram would not fit if I
installed a Raider on the top luckily
for me I had front radiator support as
well but if this case didn't have that
then I would have to get another case
RAM or hell but PC part bigger would
have never told me this same goes for
having enough fan controllers on your
motherboard I have eight case fans in my
case but my motherboard
only supported six so I had to get a
3-way fan splitter so make sure that you
guys keep all that type of stuff in mind
when you guys are building your PC and
ordering the parts overall there could
be very many small incompatibility
issues to make sure to consider those by
really researching your parts and
knowing them in and out
I watched more than 10 videos and almost
all of each of my main parts before I
zeroed in on on to the port's I was
actually going to get so it's very
important to be well-informed as a
result if you guys are well informed on
how to build a PC and well informed
about the parts you are going to use in
your build along with these tips
then billion PC will be a breeze in 2018
information about all that is so readily
available so it really is very simple as
a result don't choose pre-built because
you think that you can't build a PC it's
actually really easy
I don't hate pre-built I actually think
they are almost always cheaper around 50
to $100 beast manufacturers are able to
get their parts to pre building
companies for a bunch of cheaper price
than us asked for me
the only downfall with pre boat are
there are the inability to customize
everything to your want overall building
pcs are very fun and you guys should
definitely consider it over preebos but
pre Bo's are always a good option as
well overall building this PC was a very
fun and interesting journey for me and
it will be for you as well and so just
get informed and start building so guys
I've been thinking about making a video
in which I compared pre-built to
building and PC so if you guys are
interested in that then make sure to say
something in common
if you guys have any more questions
about this and feel free to post those
in the comments below - I heard it all
my comment I will respond so make sure
to comment any questions well that's all
I have for you guys it's time if you
guys like this video make sure to give
it a like if you guys love it and would
like to see more of you guys just like
this make sure to subscribe hit that
Bell notification but that's all I have
for you guys this time until next video
bye